mais d'abord on revient sur ce décès
suspect vendredi soir une femme de 49
ans a été retrouvée inconsciente dans
une cage d'escalier al arich
elle est décédée quelques heures plus
tard à l'hôpital son compagnon qui a
prévenu les secours est aujourd'hui
incarcéré le point sur les premiers
éléments de l'enquète avec audrey
champigny vendredi soir les secours et
la police sont appelés pour intervenir
rue de la mairie à la riche
une femme de 49 ans gîte au pied des
escaliers de son immeuble
inconsciente elle est transportée au chu
de tours où elle décédera quelques
heures plus tard c'est l'homme de 37 ans
avec lequel vit la victime qui a appelé
les secours
différentes lésions traumatiques sont
constatées sur le corps de la jeune
femme des fractures et contusions qui
peuvent être causés par un tiers ou par
sa chute dans les escaliers
son compagnon placé en garde à vue dans
la nuit conteste lui avoir porté des
coups
ils expliquent que la femme tomber
régulièrement à cause de sa consommation
importante d'alcool
un voisin du couple aurait expliqué
avoir entendu des bruits de bagarre les
jours précédents et aurait aperçu la
victime avec deux équipes aux yeux
son conjoint a été mise en examen pour
violences volontaires dans le cadre de
ce témoignage
il a été placé en détention provisoire
le top 6 du corps de la victime et des
analyses toxicologiques devaient avoir
lieu cet après midi
mais le résultat n'était pas encore
connue à l'heure où nous enregistrons ce
journal le procureur tient à préciser qu
aucune preuve pour l'instant ne permet
de conclure à un féminicide rappelant
que ce terrible fait divers s'est
déroulée dans un contexte social très
défavorisé sur fond d'alcoolisme des
deux parties